so welcome to
semester you can see up here we have the
first one was already over I hope some
of you were at Asher's talk and Tariq al
gob from Brown University is speaking
today and we have next week we have
another one from our own statistician
Jesse Suzuki and so I hope you come to
that Tariq was a graduate student here
he he wrote a really nice thesis and a
whole bunch of papers he was my student
and so I so I made him come and and give
a talk but he's well you'll enjoy him
and I think he's currently at Brown
doing a postdoc and then he'll go on to
greater things after that and that's if
you guys are interested any of you have
been becoming mathematicians that's
that's how it works you go to graduate
school and you get to play with stuff
then you get a job and they pay you to
play with more stuff so it's good to be
a mathematician okay so without further
ado Tariq invitation it's really great
to be back in New Haven and I really
think this is an amazing program so I'm
really grateful to ya year for sort of
instigating it and continuing it so
let's get started I just hit exit show
here to get out of this oh great thank
you so much we are good so we're gonna
talk today about really big numbers so
these are numbers that are so
unimaginably huge that they don't really
necessarily have names yet that we know
about they're bigger than a million a
billion a trillion
any number that you can think of these
numbers are make those numbers basically
look like zero that's how big they are
and they make any number you've ever
thought of look like one or something
they're they're gigantic I want to talk
about first of all what is a big number
what at what point do we start to
consider a number big seems like it's a
matter of opinion why do we care about
them so surely there are really big
numbers there's an
at number of numbers but why would you
ever be concerned with these really huge
ones and then how do we how do we
explore them so these these two pictures
here this one you see my laser pointer
so this picture in this picture these
are from a really excellent book called
really big numbers written by Richard
Schwartz so he was gracious enough to
allow me to use these pictures in this
talk and these are really creative ways
of actually writing down a really really
huge number so this is you can think of
this as actually being sort of just an
expression of one really big number if
you these numbers are so big that if you
try to write them down like a normal
number just digit by digit by digit you
wouldn't be able to do it not only would
it take much longer than the course of
your natural life to write it down but
there wouldn't actually be enough
physical space in the observable
universe to hold all those digits so you
have to come up with new and creative
ways of expressing a number that size
and these are ways of doing it and maybe
if there's time at the end I can
actually go back and explain what's
going on in these pictures but I think
they're just you know beautiful in their
own way so I put them there in the
introduction so let's get started and by
the way you'll have to bear with me I'm
using Prezi which is a new thing for me
so it's I'm probably gonna have some
hiccups along the way but hopefully
we'll figure it out so that's my first
slide I already talked about it let's go
here so what is a big number first of
all it the the it just happens to be
true that certain things aren't really
easy to define outright you know just
because it's a complicated concept or it
depends on opinion so what constitutes
bigness is really a subjective thing and
in that in that situation it's actually
easier to talk about what it's not and
then we build up a few examples that way
and then whatever's left over is is big
in some sense okay so what are numbers
that aren't so big
some examples so one I have wouldn't say
it's so big even a hundred it's not that
big there it is
so now so now the the definition of not
so big that we're going to use is I'm
gonna say that a number is not so big if
it's not very difficult to write it down
digit by digit so a hundred maybe you
think it's kind of a big number but
actually it only takes about one second
to write down one zero zero
we're done okay so I'm gonna say that a
number is is very big or big if you
wouldn't want to try to write it down
digit by digit because you would die
trying or there just wouldn't be enough
space to do it okay
so here's another example of of another
number that I would call not so big but
it's a bigger not so big number right so
it's much bigger than a hundred it's
it's all these nines look at all these
nines here this is one number okay and
I'm still gonna say that it's not so big
because even though it looks big it
still only took me like less than 20
seconds to write it down I just went
like this a bunch of times with my hand
on my keyboard and before I knew it I
could hold it down but Prezi is annoying
so I actually if you just hold it down
it just type someone in you can't write
so I did well I mean maybe I copy and
pasted I wrote it down five and then and
then got 10 and then 20 that way so
anyway the point is it didn't take very
long to write this down so even though
it looks big I would still say it's not
so big everybody clear on that okay so
now let me zoom in a little so that I
don't give away see I'm it's gonna be
bad hopefully okay good so this is an
example of a number that I would say is
actually kind of big now okay and the
number is this number the number you get
by writing down one and then writing
down 3 billion zeroes in a row after
that okay so everyone know what I'm
talking about what is first of all what
is 3 billion
so three billion is what it's a three
and then how many zeros yeah very close
that's three million so someone else
seven is is closer your if we keep going
on this track we'll eventually get it
right so we're talking about three
billion which is bigger than three
million so three million would be six
zeroes thirty million would be seven
zeroes someone else how about not in the
first row nine very good so one two
three four five six seven eight nine
that's three billion so three billion
itself is actually not a big number in
the way that I'm using big number right
because I wrote this number down just in
front of you and took me again just two
seconds to write it down but now I want
to think of a different number which is
the number you get by writing a one and
then this many number of zeros after
that one
so I mean you couldn't you can't imagine
just trying to write down that many
zeros it would take you forever you
wouldn't be able to do it right so one
followed by a billion zeros by the way
the number one followed by a billion
zeros doesn't have a nice fancy name
like a million or a billion or a
trillion there's no real name for that
number besides one followed by three
billion zeros that's the name okay for
this number say again now from now on
that's the new name of this number so
now we have an inventor in the front row
it's from now on this number is gonna be
called one quad zillion okay all right
but it didn't have a name before five
seconds ago and I just wrote this down
so you can actually calculate if you
tried to write this number down digit by
digit writing about one zero for every
second then it would take about 95 years
to write down and I have things to do I
have people to go people to see places
to go I'm not going to spend my entire
life doing this so this is a really big
number this is a big number okay
everyone following along
good so that's the next question we just
talked about how we wouldn't want to
spend our whole lives writing this
number down but suppose we actually
wanted a way of writing it down how
would you do it yeah beautiful so the
suggestion was we could use what's
called scientific notation okay so
another it's that's sort of a fancy a
fancy term for what's really just taking
powers of ten okay so I think that's
actually on the next slide so and
actually you can almost guess what's
happening because you could popping up
there on the left-hand side of the
projector but not if i zoom in well
anyway I tried so exactly so one
followed by two zeros what is that
that's a really weird way of just saying
a hundred right and a hundred is the
same thing as 10 raised to the power of
two okay so similarly one followed by
three zeros is a thousand and that's
just 10 to the power of three so one
followed by three billion zeros that's
the number we care about right now
that's just going to be 10 raised to the
power of three billion and instead of
having to write down 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 you
know until you're in a home somewhere
you can just write this very simple
symbol down 10 to the 3 billions power
and now we've found a much more
efficient easy way of expressing this
huge number okay so what we've learned
so far is that taking powers of 10 allow
us to move in the number line much more
quickly than just by at writing digits
right so I wanted to show you a
visualization for how quickly things
grow when you take powers of 10 so we'll
take a little field trip if this works I
think it should work this is actually a
really great
site you can go to I think you can find
it by just typing powers of 10 into
Google but it's called H twins so if I
start it oh look there's even music I
didn't know that there was music that
that's nice okay everybody see this okay
so what you're seeing right now is
objects that we would be able to see you
know with our eye without a telescope or
a microscope things that are on our
scale so a human being is roughly one
meter or so I mean really it's more like
two meters but it's on the it's close to
one meter and these are other things in
the world that are around one meter in
dimension you know in in length and
width so beach ball whatever that flower
is a dodo bird these are all things that
are you know like this this is this is
on our scale this desk is maybe it's two
meters but it's roughly on our scale
okay so now let's go out by a power of
10 let's multiply by a power of 10
whoops that's too much zoom back in a
little bit it's a little bit of a
hair-trigger here so now we're at about
10 meters and we see bigger things we
see elephants giraffes a t-rex these are
things that are you know about ten times
our size I guess this is a really huge
cactus I don't know what a saguaro
cactus is but apparently it's big yes
questions no okay they're pretty big
okay they're pretty big
good so we have confirmation that
they're big cactuses so now if we zoom
out again a little more we see some
bigger dinosaurs this has been about a
hundred meters now so ten to the power
of two everybody see this down here I'm
talking about this number here so this
is going to keep track of how many
powers of ten we've zoomed out right now
we're at ten squared that's 100 meters
and now we're seeing some even bigger
things we see we're about to see the
Titanic it's going to come into view
a football field okay that's that that's
a hundred yards it's pretty close to a
hundred meters okay so you see things
that are even bigger the International
Space Station now let's zoom out a
little more so this is this is now a
thousand meters across and we see some
bigger monuments some really tall
buildings a really really really tall
waterfall the city of Vatican City I
guess is actually smaller than a
thousand meters across okay I'm going to
zoom out a little more Central Park so
creet 'no i don't know how to pronounce
that but I think it's an asteroid so now
we see Mount Everest now we're at now
what are we at we're at 10,000 meters
across
okay so we've already in just a few
clicks we've gone from the size of a
human to the size of Mount Everest and
just four powers of 10 yes yeah it's
actually a really good point
so yeah uh-huh it's a good point
I think the point being made if I'm
allowed to paraphrase the point is that
it's not super helpful to know how big
10,000 is if you don't already know what
demos is so you should use things in
your examples that people know so you
can make the comparison and get the
point across but here at least there are
some other things that we know are quite
big like we all know Mount Everest my
nervous is huge so I'm gonna speed up a
little bit okay so now we're seeing some
you know West Virginia Rwanda is a
pretty small country moving out we see
some bigger countries a big state now
we're seeing various moons and dwarf
sized planets in our solar system and
we're only at ten to the six that's them
that's a million meters across we can
keep going out here a little bit we see
some new planets the United States now
they're at the planet Earth okay and now
we're at 10 to the seventh
we're seeing some bigger planets Neptune
Uranus minecraft all of Minecraft okay
yep Saturn some other moons have some
bigger planets about 10 to the 8th now
I'm gonna I'm gonna go a little fast all
right so bear with me the Sun is there
at ten to the ninth okay let's keep
going
all right now we're at ten to the tenth
and we're seeing some bigger stars the
Sun is actually not that big of a star
you know there are stars that are much
much bigger than the Sun keep going okay
we're seeing some bigger stars 10 to the
11 now we see the distance from Earth to
the Sun that's there as well moving out
moving out 10 to the 12 some bigger
celestial bodies all right
so this is a big cloud of gas and dust
the homunculus nebula I had to look that
up but I did this this distance here is
the amount of distance that that light
will travel in one day okay so the speed
of light is very fast so light can
travel a great distance in just one day
and that's the distance it can travel
okay moving along I'm gonna I'm gonna go
fast now okay we're just gonna see a
bunch of a bunch of things going quickly
across the screen but you see the point
the point I want to make is that we can
really see a lot of huge things by using
powers of 10 now we're at 10 to the 18th
power moving out I'm gonna go even
faster okay 10 to the 19th we're seeing
galaxies now 10 to the 20th now we're
seeing groups of galaxies together at 10
to the 23rd power
and all the way out here we see the
entire observable universe at roughly 10
to the 27th power
yes sure so zoom back in you mean ah so
sure so it looks like it's about ten to
the twenty ten to the twenty seven ten
to the twenty six so ten to the twenty
seven how would you write that down one
followed by how many zeroes exactly
that's it oh you want the name I don't
I'm not even gonna be able to tell you
if you're right I don't know the name of
one followed by 27 zeros you know it
what is it
one non-alien
nine iliyan let's see is that right yeah
well we can make up our name for it but
let's I want to keep I want to actually
now move in the other direction really
quickly okay
we're gonna move down now we got all the
way to ten to the twenty so ten to the
twenty seven meters across is the entire
observable universe we're talking about
a number that is one followed by three
billion zeros let alone one followed by
just a mere 27 zeros okay so the numbers
we're talking about vastly dwarfed the
the size and meters of the entire
observable universe now let's move down
all the way back in zooming in zooming
in zooming in blah blah blah moving
through the whole universe okay now
we're back down oops I went too far this
is about our size right remember this is
what we started now we can zoom in we
see some small animals some small eggs
of birds a marble a coffee bean an ant
now we're at 10 to the minus 4 everybody
know what 10 to the minus 4 is that's
like what is that that's 1 divided by 1
followed by 4 zeros so it's like oh one
ten-thousandth of 1 meter so we're
moving now smaller smaller smaller okay
speed up a little bit now we just saw
DNA go by us now we're seeing the
hydrogen atom at 10 to the minus 10 okay
it's one of the small I guess that's the
smallest atom right the hydrogen atom
yep it's the smallest atom moving down
moving down moving down we see various
subatomic particles moving down what is
this that's a cork at 10 to the minus 22
corks I guess they're little pieces of a
proton right is that right or pieces of
all of the subatomic particles are made
of these tinier things called quarks so
good I'm glad we have someone in the
audience who knows moving down none
there's not much here actually okay I'm
just gonna keep going and now we're at
the Planck length which is really it's
the it's it's the length under which the
physics that we know breaks down we
don't really know how to describe the
physics of the universe under this scale
so you may as well think of the Planck
length as being the smallest sort of
scale of the whole universe and it's at
10 to the minus 35 okay so now we can
see the point is what's the point the
biggest thing in the whole universe is
the universe itself and that was at 10
to the 27 right the Planck length is the
smallest thing and that's at 10 to the
minus 35 so the moral of this story is
that the entire every physical object
you can possibly conceive of fits in
less than 70 powers of 10 right so 35
plus 27 is less than 70 so all of these
everything you can ever conceive of
physically fits in this
all amount of numbers of powers of ten
okay let's go back to the presentation
okay alright so that's basically what
this slide is saying the whole universe
fits in only 62 powers of 10 and the
second sort of interesting lesson that
you might want to get from this is that
we are at about one meter in scale right
the largest thing in the universe is 10
to the 27 and the smallest thing is 10
to the minus 35 a lot of these
demonstrations of powers of 10 they can
make you feel very small like the
universe is this vast thing in
watermeion just this little speck of
dust I'm nothing compared to all but you
should not get that that lesson because
actually we are bigger than we are small
because 35 is bigger than 27 so we're a
lot bigger than the smallest thing in
the universe then we are smaller than
the biggest thing in the universe we're
more than halfway towards the biggest
thing okay does that make sense okay
so now let's get to a question of why if
our whole universe fits in just sixty
two powers of ten why would we even need
a number like 10 to the three billion to
talk about anything and right so that's
the answer the answer is is that math is
first of all a lot cooler than the real
world so the real world it has to follow
certain rules it's just that's the way
it is you know certain things are and
certain things are not and we're bound
by that reality and math there are also
rules you have to follow but it's much
more flexible we're bound really only by
a small number of rules and our
imaginations which can take us far
beyond what how big or how small
physical reality is so maybe if you
don't like that answer a better answer a
slightly better answer is that actually
numbers like 10 to the 3 billion and
numbers that are much
much much bigger than 10 to 3 billion
they come up actually in mathematics
we're going to see an example of this
soon but there are examples of
mathematical theorems that were proved
only by referring to numbers that are
way bigger than 10 to the 3 billions so
if we're going to do that kind of math
we need a way of writing down those
kinds of huge numbers and and the second
point is that when we figure out new and
better ways to talk about big numbers it
actually is one way of inventing new and
cool math right so to talk about a
number like 10 to the 3 billion power
and to write it down we had to first
invent taking powers of 10 that's kind
of a mathematical tool that is sort of
more advanced than just adding one
adding one adding one and if we want to
talk about numbers that are even bigger
than 10 to the three billion we're going
to have to invent new math just to be
able to do that and that's interesting
in its own right okay so now we're gonna
focus on one of my favorite numbers
it's called Graham's number and so this
slide is just talking about a little bit
of history this number so a pair of
mathematicians Ronald Graham and bl
Rothschild invented this well they
didn't invent the number really I mean
the number was always there but they
gave a name for it and they talked about
how to express it and they did it during
the proof of a result in a field of math
called Ramsey theory I'm not going to
say much about what Ramsey theory is
it'll take us to far afield but I'm very
happy to talk more about it afterwards
I just gave a little bit of a slide here
just sort of giving a sentence on Ramsey
theory so what is it
so really Ramsey theory it's it's a it's
a it's a branch of mathematics the moral
of the story of Ramsey theory is that
when you have giant giant giant
collections of objects you have to start
seeing patterns forming in them they
just have to be there if there's two if
there's so many of a certain kind of
object you have to start
seeing them cluster into certain kinds
of patterns on smaller scales that's all
I'll say about Ramsey theory and again
I'm really more than happy to talk about
this specific problem that they were
solving when they came up with Graham's
number after but I want to just first
try to give you an exam number is and
then we're gonna actually talk about how
to write it down okay so so Graham's
number is is extremely huge that's still
about Ramsey theory let's move to the
next slide sorry okay so before we try
to talk about really how big it is I
first want to come up with a way of
quantifying how big a big number is okay
so here's how we're gonna do that see
the pointer if I give you any number n
then the digits of n is just going to
mean the number of digits of n okay so
how many digits the seven has just one
right the digits of 276 is three how
many did is this does this guy have yeah
so that's there are probably only about
ten numbers I wrote here that's true but
the number of digits of this number is
actually much bigger than 10 another
suggestion three billion three billion
and one that is correct right so so so
does that make sense it's three billion
and one right because if I if I write
down 10 to the six what is that that's
one million which is one followed by six
zeros so it's six plus one so 10 to the
three billion is going to just be have
three billion in one digits right I
think I probably made a mistake here I
did I'm just gonna ignore that by
zooming in now we can't see it anymore
okay so so what is our definition of a
big number just to remind you a big
number is any number that we would take
of that would take a very very long time
to write down digit by digit okay so
we'll say that a big number is of big
level one if it's number of digits is
itself not a big number everyone
understand what I'm saying
so for instance let's do an example an
example is 10 to the 3 billion is
certainly a big number right because I
wouldn't be able to write it down digit
by digit but how many digits does 10 to
the 3 billion have it's 3 billion and 1
even though I wrote down it's only 3
billion it should be 3 billion and 1 and
3 billion and 1 is not a big number by
our definition because I can write it
down very easily 3 billion and 1 is not
hard to write down everyone follow me so
if a number has the property that it's
number of digits is not big then we say
it's only big of level one okay so but
what about this crazy number down here
now it's 10 to the 10 to the 3 billion
see this number here crazy right
I'm crazy you're right so how many
digits does this guy have well if I just
take the digits of 10 to the 10 to the 3
billion
how many did how many digits does that
have it's it's it's 10 to the 3 billion
plus 1 right that's what we said
whenever you do 10 to the blank the
number of digits of that thing is blank
plus 1 right remember that so the number
of digits of 10 to the 10 to the 3
billion is just 10 to the 3 billion plus
1 and that is itself a really big number
right
so 10 to the 10 to the 3 billion is
actually going to be big of level 2 okay
everyone following me it's gonna get
much crazier this is this is really
level zero of our of this talk okay so
so hold on to your hats okay so all I'm
saying here is explaining that right if
we try to take the digits of 10 to the
10 to the 3 billion can you see my
clicker the number of digits is itself a
big number however if we again asked for
the digits so we first take the digits
we get a number and then we take digits
of that number will only get really 3
billion and 1 which is not that big
because I can write it down very easily
and then we're gonna say that the
original number we started with was big
of level two okay so let's see what did
I write here in general the level of a
big number is just the number of times
we have to successively ask for the
digits over and over again until we end
up with a number that is not big is that
does that make sense ok so there are
absolutely humongous gigantic
mind-bogglingly big numbers that have
small levels okay so for instance look
at this number down here 10 to the 10 to
the 10 to the 10 to the 10 that number
is blows anything we've talked about so
far completely out of the water okay 10
to the 3 billion was huge okay but this
number I mean it's impossible to even
really describe right because how many
digits does 10 to the 10 to the 10 to
the 10 to the 10 have it's this number
of digits it's the number of of the
exponent and the exponent is itself 10
to the 10 to the 10 to the 10 and that's
way bigger than tenth to then then three
billion for this number is gigantic but
what is its level
three three we have a suggestion of
three well we have a sedition of five
also five and three you're saying 2:10
says actually I'd never exactly I I
wrote three I don't know why I did that
let's see so it's definitely smaller
than four right because if I write down
ten to the so how many digits let's just
do it right now this is a good exercise
to make sure we're all following along
so how many digits does 10 to the 10 to
the 10 to the 10 to the 10 have well we
said that whenever you have 10 to the
blank the number of digits is just
whatever the exponent is plus 1 right
and so now how many digits does that
thing have 10 to the 10 to the 10 to the
10 plus 1 I can basically ignore the
plus 1 that's not going to change the
number of digits so the number of digits
of this thing is again just going to be
the exponent here and then plus 1 so
it's basically 10 to the 10 to the 10
plus 1 okay so far so good so what is 10
to the 10 10 to the 10 is 1 followed by
10 zeros right so this is really like 10
to the roughly 10 billion that's still
too big for me to try to write down so
I'm not quite done yet I have to keep
going
so digits of this digits 10 to the 10 to
the 10 plus 1 by the exact same pattern
what are you gonna get 10 to the 10 plus
1 and now actually that is that's not
hard to write down at all because it's
just 1 followed by 10 zeros 5 6 7 8 9
and then a 1 because I had to add 1 so
let's see so we did it one time we got a
really big number so it's not big of
level one
we did it a second time we still got a
really big number so it's not big of
level-2 but doing it a third time brings
us down to a number we can actually
write so it is big of level three but
three is three is not big right so you
can get to huge numbers and they still
have tiny levels right okay so how big
is Graham's number whoops go in go in go
in how big is Graham's number well we
can ask how big it is by talking about
what is its level right and the crazy
thing about Graham's number is that it's
so big that it's level is itself a
really big number okay these guys this
this if this number was gigantic and its
level was only three so Graham's number
is so big that it's level is itself a
number that I can't write down everyone
following okay so that's kind of scary
right what that actually means
if you think about it what that means is
that we cannot write down Graham's
number just by using powers of ten so we
had a suggestion from this from over
here in the audience how do we write
down one followed by three billion zeros
the answer was scientific notation use
powers of ten but the fact that the
number of levels itself is a big number
means that you're never going to be able
to write down Graham's number by just
using that same trick because the number
of levels if you think about it it's
really just using more and more powers
of ten that's what we saw here right the
number of the number of digits is
basically just the exponent and that
takes away one power of 10 so we're
never gonna be able to write down in
Graham's number by using the technology
that we know which is taking powers of
ten we're gonna have to come up with a
crazier thing sorry but we can we can
even we we can even talk about take
more levels right so grands number is so
big that it's level is a big number
right but now I can take the level of
that thing that thing is still get the
level of that thing will still be a big
number and I can take the level of that
thing and that's still gonna be a big
number the number of times that I do
this process of taking levels and levels
and levels and levels before I get down
to a small number is itself a big number
so levels are just not going to work for
expressing Graham's number all right so
we're gonna have to invent some new
tools for doing this okay so before we
even talk about these new tools let's
first of all just remind ourselves some
facts about basic arithmetic okay so
multiplication what is it well it's it's
many things but one thing you can think
about it as being is it's really just a
shortcut way of writing addition so five
times seven five times seven is much
better way of writing 5 plus 5 Plus 5
Plus 5 Plus 5 plus five plus five seven
copies of it right it's much more
efficient to just write five times seven
it just so happens that multiplication
is nice in that five times seven is the
same thing as seven times five so it's
also the same thing as seven plus seven
plus seven plus seven plus seven right
question no okay no question okay so in
the exact same way
taking exponents is a shortcut way of
doing multiplication right because five
raised to the power of seven is the same
thing as 5 times 5 times 5 times 5 times
5 times 5 times 5 right so exponential
no matter which way you do it so it's
not true that five to the 7 is 7 to the
5 like what happened with it with
multiplication but it is still true that
taking powers is a shortcut way of doing
multiple
occasion just like how multiplication
was a shortcut way of doing addition
okay good so that's that's something we
all know and love the key insight is why
would I stop there let's just make yet
another thing it doesn't have a name I
don't know what it is but it's it's
beyond taking exponents but whatever it
is it's gonna be a way of doing
exponents in a shortcut way just like
how doing multiplication was a shortcut
way of addition and how taking exponents
was a shortcut way of multiplication
we'll make up a whole new operation that
will be a shortcut way of taking
exponents okay so we're just gonna write
we're just going to use this this
notation of an arrow because I don't
there is no notation really so I'm just
will make something up and it's just
it's just a single arrow and five arrow
seven will be a faster way of writing
five to the five to the five to the five
to the five to the five to the five okay
everybody okay with that by the way do
we know how to even do let's make sure
that we know what that number is
I mean it's gigantic but if I see
something like this how do i how do i
compute what that is where do I start
yeah exactly exactly the whole what I
want to make clear is that when you see
iterated exponents like this you have to
work in and go out so the first thing I
have to do is figure out what this is
that's gonna be some big number and then
I do five to the bat
okay so if I see five to the 5 to the 5
to the 5 to the 5 to the blah blah blah
blah that's I mean I can't even describe
how big that is because the very first
thing I have to do is first figure out
what is what is just 5 to the 5 that's
all the way up here then I do 5 to the
power of that and then 5 to the power of
whatever that is and so on and so on and
I work my way down and when I get down
to the very
it's gargantuan okay but that's what it
means to do five arrow seven everyone
following okay so this allows us to
write very very big numbers in a pretty
efficient way for instance if I think
about three up arrow 3 three arrow three
that number is so much bigger than 10 to
the three billions power and that was
the big number we've been working with
the entire talk so far okay the
difference between three arrow three and
10 to the three billion is much much
much more vast than the difference
between a plank length and the entire
universe okay so using small numbers
like threes and this arrow notation
already gives us something that's way
way way bigger than 10 to the 3 billions
power okay so the point is like now
we've opened up a Pandora's box like why
would you ever stop at just inventing
one new operation let's just keep going
right we already have this one arrow
well now let's just make another one
called two arrow and two arrow is this
gonna be a shortcut way of writing the
one arrow operation just like how the
one arrow was the shortcut way of doing
multiplication just so sorry
exponentiation just like how
exponentiation was looking for model so
on and so on and so on okay so we make
yet a new operation which will be a
shorthand way for doing many copies of
arrow everybody follow so we'll write it
like two arrows and now five arrow arrow
seven is the same thing as just doing
seven copies of the one arrow notation
for five that it's the exact same
pattern we're just we're just scaling up
once more okay so we there's no way we
can even contemplate the size of five
arrow arrow seven it's just I mean I
can't even I can't we can't do it but I
do want to just go through the first
couple of steps of how to actually
compute this number just so we can begin
to wrap our minds around what we're
dealing with okay
so here's that slide it's gonna get
scary but just bear with me all right
no no no come on you can do it good so
let's start here so just to make sure
you're following so what is five arrow
arrow seven what is five arrow arrow
seven it is it's it's exactly this it's
it's five arrow five arrow five arrow
five seven times right the first thing I
can do though let me I'm gonna write
this down on the board hopefully we can
see I don't know what this is I'm gonna
leave it up I assume it's there for a
reason so five arrow five arrow
5:05 that's four so far arrow five arrow
5:05 this is equal to well the first
thing again I have to go in and work my
way out so the first thing I can do is
figure out what is five arrow five what
is five out of five yeah not quite so
the suggestion was 25 zeros five
followed by 25 zeros it's actually much
bigger than that
is there another suggestion beautiful
beautiful so this is remember this what
this means is a shortcut way of writing
exponents so this is going to be five to
the five to the five to the five to the
five that's what just this one part is
and now what I have to do is work my way
out so now I'll do five arrow this thing
okay and what does that mean it means I
do five to the five to the five to the
five to the five to the five to the five
to the five to the five to the five the
number the the number of fives I see in
that tower is equal to this number okay
everyone everyone see what I'm saying
okay so that's what I've written here
right I just now you'll only see six of
these things
so where did I leave my laser point
it's here so now you see just one two
three four five six
but this six thing is now the what you
get by doing five arrow five and now I
keep going out like this so what is this
if i zoom go down a little bit okay as I
said just now that's the same thing
again I can collapse one further arrow
down and I'll get 500 500 500 5 and then
what is five air of this thing it's
exactly what I get by taking a tower of
fives whose height is 5 to the 5 to the
5 to the 5 to the 5 ok does that make
sense
should we keep going let's keep going
alright well go a little further and
then we'll stop alright so now I can I
can collapse again right and now I only
see three arrows but the but this last
guy here right what is it
it's some Tower of fives right anyone
know how to how to think about this
anyone what does this mean what does
this notation mean so we're really
saying is that sorry any any any
suggestions for what this means
yeah yeah just this last thing I want to
understand what is this yes yes exactly
exactly
that's a beautiful answer so I mean
really all that's happening here is
we're just expanding out again right so
here what is this it's a tower of five s
whose height is 5 to the 5 to the 5 to
the 5 to the 5 now that's just one thing
right what that's a gigantic number but
I don't know what it is okay let's call
it George
okay so George is this is this number
this whole number
right and now if I want to get rid of
this arrow to do it I would say v ^ v ^
v ^ v - the george x okay and we can
call that number john if we wanted and
now we can keep going alright so this is
just to give you an idea of what of how
quickly these operations get us - huge
huge numbers numbers that just destroy
put to shame any number we've talked
about so far okay but again we know what
we're gonna say next which is we would
be we would be cheating ourselves really
to stop at only two arrows right I mean
like why would we do that we can now we
can make yet another operation which is
called three arrow and that's gonna be a
shortcut way of writing the two arrow
thing and we can do another operation
called the four arrow which is just a
shortcut way of writing two three and so
on and so on and so on so this is like
this is what we're seeing here is a
basic tool in mathematics called
recursive definitions where you can make
a sequence of new things by referring to
the new thing that you just made okay
and so we get this gigantic collection
of new operations which each make the
previous one look like nothing that's
how quickly they're growing in terms of
how fast they can allow us to approach
gigantic numbers and I I didn't actually
I lied to you so I said we're gonna make
up this arrow thing so someone actually
did make up this arrow thing it's called
connotes up arrow notation question we
could do it down arrow notation and
maybe a down arrow notation we could do
even more we could do more we could make
them even bigger but you will get there
actually it's a great great suggestion
we could maybe down arrow is like the
same thing but making smaller numbers I
don't know like you know one over a big
number we can't we let your creativity
run wild you can make all kinds of crazy
operations okay so now we're finally
arriving at how to talk about Graham's
number okay let's remember the whole
point of this was just so I could tell
you about one number it
graham's number okay so Graham's number
to get there we have to get there in
stages I can't just tell you what it is
right away you know it's like a mystical
thing or something you know you can't
you can't be told what it is you have to
you have to discover it yourself so the
first stage of discovery is this number
okay three up arrow up arrow up arrow up
arrow 3 okay we just saw what happened
when we tried to do just two up arrows
and we couldn't even we couldn't even
conceive of that all right
so through so four up arrows in a row
with a three on either side is just I
can't even we can't talk about it but
let me give you some let me give you
some idea of what it might look like
alright so just to give you some idea
alright so what is that
literally what it is just by definition
is just it's a shortcut way of writing
the three arrow notation right so it's
three up arrow up arrow up arrow 3 up
arrow up arrow up arrow 3 right that's
what it is everybody following that so
far I don't know what this is but
certainly it's equal to that okay okay
but now what is that I can rewrite that
using just three up arrow up arrow up
arrow and then some Tower of threes and
the point is is that if each of these
threes was about two centimeters tall
which is roughly I don't know how how I
write then the thought the the the size
of this tower would go from the ground
to the Sun so does that can can you can
we imagine that for a second so remember
let's let's go to the next slide just to
give you an idea of what of how big that
is
so remember that three up arrow three is
way way way bigger than 10 to the three
billions power right so what is what is
three up arrow 3 what is it
three up arrow 3 is just 3 to the 3 to
the 3 right so this number is already
way bigger than the big number we
started with and this is only three
threes I'm saying put a number of threes
in this tower that would take you from
here to the Sun and that's that's not
even the number I'm talking about that's
just part of it okay should we keep
going
die mess up so there's a there's a
discrepancy so let's see so three oh
you're right you're right I do I do
thank you there should be like this and
this is not quite right you're right
it's not quite bigger than then then our
big number but if I had 3 to the 3 and 3
to the 3 whatever four threes you're
right there's a mistake thank you this
would already be much bigger than then
10 to the 3 billion and it's only four
threes and I'm talking about you need
and you need the number of threes that
would take you from here to the Sun okay
and this is not even this is not even
the number I'm talking the number I'm
talking about is this remember it's
three arrow oh geez
sorry I don't know how that happened
it's three arrow arrow arrow arrow three
which we which we deduced was the same
thing as this and all I'm talking about
is just this part of it we still have to
figure out what these arrows are gonna
do in this three and that's not Graham's
number sorry to say okay that's just
stage one we have to go through a few
more stages to get the Graham's number
so what is stage two stage two is what
you get by doing three and then some
number of arrows and then a three and
what that number of arrows is is the
stage one number okay
so I mean I'm not gonna just continue to
say what I've been saying over and over
again which is this big I mean it's big
it's really big but now now we just
repeat this so what is stage 3 stage 3
is going to be a 3 followed by the
number of arrows that equals stage 2 and
then a 3 it's the exact same trick we
used to define the arrows in the first
place it's again this recursive
definition right we can do stage 4 by
just writing a 3 and then the number of
arrows which is equal to stage 3 and
then a 3 and we get a stage 5 and a
stage 6 and a stage 7 and a stage 8 so
Graham's number is stage 64 of this
process okay
all right how're y'all are y'all good
with that you shouldn't be good with it
it should make you queasy it really
should yeah the reason so the question
is what's the reason for doing three and
sixty four stages and the answer is
again this number popped up in the
course of a mathematical proof okay
these two mathematicians were trying
they were really trying to prove that
something was finite and in fact they
proved that it was less than Graham's
number so it's finite but it's huge and
in fact this was in 1971 okay when they
first came up with this proof whatever
they were trying to count and prove that
it's finite they proved it was less than
Graham's number but since that time
they're proof has been improved and
improved and improved by many other
people it's now known that the answer is
either 11 or 12 okay
but that's how math works you know at
first you have to stop the bleeding
and then and then you can really improve
on it as you go on through the decades
okay so the answer there's no there's no
really theoretical answer to your
question it's just that's what worked
for their purposes okay but the
interesting thing about this now
this is that it you know you they had
you have to create these new
mathematical technologies to even
express the number in the first place
so it's it's until noon right so I guess
maybe I can I have time for one more one
more slide and I'll just sort of sort of
tease you I have a few more slides down
the down the pipeline but I'll stop here
I think I've already made everyone
queasy enough as it is but the bottom
line is that Graham's number is really
nothing compared to even bigger numbers
ok and since we've defined these arrow
notations people have really taken off
with it you can probably tell you know
we already have suggestions in the
audience for making new operations and
you can do that and you can make even
crazier operations and you can get
numbers that make Graham's number look
like one really so if you're interested
in learning more about this you should
look up the busy beaver sequence it's a
it's a term from computer science and
from the intersection of mathematics and
computer science it's a sequence of
numbers that grows so fast so fast that
I don't know for certain I mean no one
knows the exact values of this of the
sequence because they the numbers
involved are just so gigantic but
certainly the 50th number in the
sequence is already way bigger than
Graham's number so imagine the Graham's
number seaton element of that busy
beaver sequence if you want a huge
number so let me just scroll through
these last couple of things I'm not
going to talk about this nope
no I just want to get to this slide just
to let you know some resources if you
want to learn more so again I mention
from the very beginning this book called
really big numbers by Richard Evans
warts it's a beautiful book with really
nice animations that you can look
through flip through if you want to
learn more about these ideas and then
here are a couple of websites you can go
to to learn more about Graham's number
learn about the busy beaver sequence
things like that so thank you for your
time and attention and that's all thanks
thank you very much so before we finish
are there any questions for our speaker
beyond what we already had yes oh you
wanted to gather slides yeah we could do
that maybe instead of showing you them
which will take a while I'll just speak
30 seconds more about what they say does
that work and then if you'd like I can
show you in person down here afterwards
but basically the busy beavers sequence
is it's something that comes from
computer science where what is what is
the v busy beaver number just to give
you an example 5 v busy beaver number is
you look at all computer programs that
use fewer than really 5 number of
symbols to write down completely and
then you look at all of them there's
only finitely many such programs because
you can only you know write 5 symbols in
a finite number of ways and you see the
one that takes the longest time to
terminate do you know the longest
running time and and that's that's the
fifth busy beaver number so it's kind of
it kind of maxes out the amount of time
it would take to run any computer
program of that size and and it grows so
fast that actually it you know almost by
definition it grows much faster than any
sequence which could be computed by a
computer like somehow you get a kind of
self-referring contradiction if you
could actually build a computer program
that could compute those numbers because
then it would have to be referencing
that as its own as another program in
the definition of itself and it's just
what you'd get a contradiction so they
it grows faster than any sequence that
can be computed by a computer yeah
that's a really great question so the
question was since you can write a
number down using decimals isn't each
number itself kind of infinite because
they have an infinite number of digits
if you use decimals so one is really the
same thing as one point zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero forever
and so aren't they all infinite and
that's a really great question so there
are really sort of two different kinds
of infinity you can talk about the value
of the number itself which is one or you
can talk about sort of the number of
digits that it takes to write down that
number and where you put the decimal
point will determine the size the actual
size of the number so in other words
this is that you're asking a question
that confused famous philosophers for
centuries so maybe it's not something
that can be described really well in the
next 15 seconds but there's really two
kinds of infinities there's the kind
that looks like this where you go off
forever and you don't see and it's just
all the way out here you never get there
but then there's this other kind of
infinity of like for instance one and
then one and a half and then one in
three quarters and then one and you know
whatever's next seven eighths etc etc
and you can see an infinite number of
steps along the way from just going from
one to two this kind of infinity you
never get there but this kind of
infinity you get there somehow and
you're talking about the second one
Zeno's paradox exactly so this is a
version of Zeno's paradox which which
was very confusing to a lot of it's
still confusing to me
but it's the bottom line is how could I
ever get from one to two if I have to
take an infinite number of steps along
the way and the decimal points that
you're talking about they tell you about
this infinite number of steps so you're
talking about the second kind of
infinity and I'm talking about the first
kind of infinity so the answer to your
question is in some sense you can think
of numbers as being infinite because
they contain sort of all of the numbers
that came before them and there's an
infinite number of spaces between one
and two but it's not the infinite that
I'm talking about which is the first one
okay yes
so besides the mathematical theorems are
these very large numbers used anywhere
else so I guess it depends on how you
define a mathematical theorem so I would
say that a lot of the things that are
done in computer science are also
themselves mathematical theorems but
maybe they have like more application if
you like because it's like about
computers so these really big numbers
also show up there a lot you know people
are interested in developing faster and
better ways of doing huge computations
and you know maybe you've heard about
how like people compete about how to
write programs to compute the most
number of digits of pi or how to like
factorize really large primes so
similarly people compete with how do you
use computers and algorithms to express
bigger and bigger and bigger numbers and
it moves the field forward it drives it
drives research and it's just kind of
beautiful and it's a way to kind of
explore the infinite number line but I
mean that's more mathematical the answer
to your question is also in computer
science
in astronomy so the question is what
about in astronomy so the answer to that
quote an astronomer so if there is an
astronomer in the room feel free to
correct what I'm about to say but I
would probably say the answer is no and
it's exactly because of those examples
we saw everything in the whole universe
is contained in a mirror
62 powers of 10 if you're using the
scale of meters so there's no real need
for numbers of this size to describe
actual celestial bodies or even atoms or
anything anything in between so the
physical universe probably doesn't
require thinking about these kinds of
numbers except for the fact that maybe
you have a mathematical theorem that it
might be motivated by something in
physical reality and so it's saying
something about reality but in order to
prove it you might need to reference
these kinds of big numbers I mean that
could that could conceivably come up I
can talk more about that in person but
yeah how about chaos so I mean I could
make a very tenuous and not a kind of
cheap connection that you know if I if
gone to my head probably we could do it
but it's not I don't see any direct
relationship between these huge numbers
in chaos theory so but that doesn't mean
there isn't one
I just don't know
again
you